well this is Vince Morrow an associate
professor at the Scripps Research
Institute I'm going to be talking about
code on optimization today and there'll
be a question and answer session at the
end but feel free to post your questions
any time during the presentation at the
end there will be a link so that you can
learn educational credits so the
technology I'm going to be talking about
today is code on optimization and this
is a gene engineering approach that's
used pretty extensively to increase
protein production predominantly it's
used for recombinant protein drugs gene
therapy DNA and RNA vaccines and it's
it's very probably used but recently
it's become clear that codon
optimisation is not neutral and can have
a number of effects on the protein
that's being expressed including
affecting the conformation of the
protein its function in some cases you
you increase the immunogenicity or
reduce the efficacy so even though
you're making more protein you may be
having these negative effects these
these problems have been discussed
before and I'll just briefly review them
but the point of this talk is on some
new hazards some potentially new hazards
of quote on optimization particularly
for in vivo applications which things
like gene therapy and genetic vaccines
so the topic code on optimization so
code on optimizations been you know
widely used with protein drugs biotech
drugs and I mean it turns out that
proteins have some proteins of important
therapeutic value and since the you know
a lot of these proteins are found in
your body they have a lot of advantages
in terms of safety and dosing and so on
and these proteins can be administered
two ways either as drugs or
can be expressed in vivo so in the
person and when you're when you're
making a protein as a drug you can
express it you coli there's a lot of
different production systems eased
insect mammalian cells there's
transgenic plants and animals the most
most of these proteins are expressed in
Chinese hamster ovary cells this is a
cell line of choice because very good
growth properties or good expression
properties but you can also express
therapeutic proteins or antigens in vivo
gene therapy mRNA therapy DNA and RNA
vaccines in these cases the constructs
are inside the patient and the protein
synthesis is occurring inside the person
so in either case if you're if you're
making it a therapeutic protein as an
industrial scale process or if you're
expressing in a you know in a pro in a
person you have to have protein
synthesis and so this is a biological
process that occurs in the cells and so
if you're if you're expressing in a cell
line or for example a DNA vaccine a-- or
gene therapy you introduce a construct
with a gene of interest and here in the
DNA the gene of interest would be the
blue segment which is transcribed into
messenger RNA which is translated into a
protein if you're if you're working it
with RNA therapeutics or RNA vaccines
that you just sites get around the DNA
steps you may be the RNA in vitro and
you start with the RNA and the RNA is
translated into protein now that the
translation process itself consists of
three steps fundamentally initiation
elongation and termination and so the
initiation step is where you get a
translation ribosomal complex so they
have the 40s and 60s ribosomal subunits
forming at the start site of protein
synthesis and this is typically an Aug
triplet an Aug codon you want
Asian is the process whereby the the
ribosome decodes the message and makes a
peptide and termination there stop codon
so at the end of a coding sequence the
protein synthesis will stop the complex
will dissociate and the subunits can be
reused and the peptide is released so in
order to understand codon optimization
at a deeper level things important to
review initiation and elongation so the
process can be better understood
so the initiation step involves the
small 40s ribosomal subunit which is the
this little green blob attached to the
purple squiggle the purple squiggle is a
tRNA the initiator methionine tRNA and
it's associated with the small ribosomal
subunit and this is important finding
the spot in the message where
translation initiates and this is
typically an Aug triplet an Aug codon
and the tRNA base pairs to the Aug codon
when this happens and so the initiator
tRNA is is covalently linked to its
amino acid with which is Metheny and
when this happens then the large
ribosomal subunit comes in and you forms
what's called an AVS ribosomal complex
when this happens the tRNA is positioned
in the p site of the large subunit and
so now that the next step is is when
elongation begins and so the next codon
in this message if the translation goes
in a 5 prime to 3 prime direction is GGG
and so the next tRNA that can recognize
that codon will come into the a site and
its base pairs to the GGG then what
happens is the ribosome has Pepa do
transfer activity so the Metheny an
amino acid on that first trna becomes
linked to the glycine on the second and
and so now you have the original tRNA
vacant of an amino acid and you have a
dipeptide Matt gly on the second tRNA
now the ribosomal subunit shifts it
moves three nucleotides one codon in the
five prime to three prime direction and
so now the empty the vacant tRNA is in
the e site and the dipeptide containing
tRNA is in the P site the empty the
vacant tRNA is ejected and the process
is then repeated right so the next codon
g ug well you get a shift so the next g
ug thickness this is valine so this
encodes valine and so the baleen tRNA
comes in then you get a pepper do
transfers react transferase reactions
and I have Mac lavell hooked to the
valine tRNA the ribosome ships the the
vacant tRNA is a jacket and so on in
this this process continues until you
reach the stop codon at which point the
the the peptide is released and and the
subunits dissociate and start over
and so that cartoon illustrates
elongation but I think it's important to
remember that different amino acids can
be encoded by more than one codon right
so there are 20 amino acids and only
only methionine and tryptophan are
included by single codons all of the
others are included by 2 3 4 or 6 so 61
codons encode 20 amino acids the
remaining three are stop codons but
when you think about codon usage and
translation an important consideration
is wobble although it's often ignored I
think and it's interesting because many
many cells have less than 61 tRNAs and
61 would be what you would need if every
codon had a tRNA corresponding to it
right but but this isn't the case but
nevertheless messages still contain all
of the codons and it can still be
translated and it can be decoded because
of wobbles so wobble was originally
proposed by by pricks in the 1960s and
suggested that when you're decoding the
first two nucleotides in the codon base
pair by standard watching Crick base
pairing but the base pairing rules are
relaxed for the third position right so
so you can for example have GU base
pairing and because of wobble there are
some P RNAs that combine to several
codons for the same amino acid and so if
we look at codon anticodon base pairing
so what we see is that the codon and so
the messages is indicated in the five
prime to three prime direction and the
codon is three nucleotides one two three
and codon three is the Wobble position
and this base pairs to a tRNA which is
indicated by this box structure but so
each box is just a nucleotide and
there's a three nucleotides in the tRNA
which is called the anticodon which is
nucleotides 34 35 and 36 so nucleotide
34 base pairs to the third position this
is the wall this is the Wobble
interaction now it's a little more
complicated because four four seven of
the tRNAs in yeast and eight in
eukaryotes the adenosine x' in position
34 get deaminated to inosine
and this is important because it's a it
changes the the base period potential of
that of that nucleotide so if we look at
a
anticodon code on interaction if you had
a you in position 34 it can be spared to
a at the third quote on position or it
could wobble base pair to G a G could be
spared as CE or wobble bass bear to you
and anything could compare to you C or a
right so that this just expands the the
possibility of what tRNAs can be code
and there's a there's another what might
be a special case or not
which is described in chloroplasts which
is called super wobble and in the
chloroplasts it turns out that 25 tRNAs
are sufficient for for survival so
that's all you need and the the reason
this can occur is because of super
wobble which is an unmodified you in
position 34 which space pairs which can
be spread to CGA or you whether it
occurs in in other cellular systems is
not known yet but it's a possibility
now this codon table can be represented
in different ways in here I've
represented resented it in a circular
configuration and here I'm trying to
show wobble codon uses and presence or
absence of tRNA genes in human and and
so the outside ring is the amino acid
and this is a single letter code for the
for the amino acids then the codon
itself is is the inner middle and outer
nucleotide rings are the first second
and third positions of the of the codon
and and the green bars indicate the
codons that are capable of wobble
pairing to a tRNA the adenosine
interaction the blue bars show where you
we have wobble GU or ug wobble the great
bars this is a trying to indicate code
on frequency so this is this is the you
know zero to a hundred white to black
the the frequency at which the different
codons are are used they show up and I
have more descent put on frequency but
so that the level of gray indicates how
often those codons are used and the red
indicates tRNA is that that lack of tRNA
gene so you can see in human there are
thirteen tRNAs that don't have a
corresponding gene right this is this
kind of interesting now if you look at
codon usage and presence or absence of a
tRNA gene but i mean if we just look at
prolene so you can see that the codon
ccc does not have a tRNA corresponding
to that codon but it's it's used with a
certain frequency indicated by the gray
if you look at CCU it's used with about
the same frequency although this one
does have a gene that corresponds to so
though in those two examples they're
used about the same even though one has
a gene and the other one doesn't and if
you look at CCG the gene it has a gene
present but i was used much less right
so you can it appears as if the presence
or absence of a tRNA gene does it
doesn't appear to affect the
distribution of the codon usage and so
just to kind of drive the point home a
little bit more as so synonymous codon
changes don't tell tur the amino acid
composition of protein just just the
mRNA sequence so in this example mat 3
hiss peptide is encoded it's the same
peptide but it's encoded by by mRNAs
that differ at different nucleotide
positions so different
different messages can give rise to the
same protein so discuss a little bit
about codon optimisation so this is an
approach whereby synonymous codons are
used to change the message and the the
main purpose is whether opposing some
any purpose one of the main purposes is
to to increase protein expression
facilitating gene gene synthesis this is
the second and so I'd like to just
discuss this a little bit so how do have
it how did people even come to do codon
optimization and some of that is
historical right so initially the first
recombinant Pepa that was expressed
amount of statin it was made in e.coli
and they made this without even knowing
the mRNA sequence right so they reversed
translated the amino acid sequence to
obtain a coding sequence and and since
they didn't know what the natural codon
uses was they could use whatever codons
they wanted and they biased it in a
certain way to suit to suit their needs
and so they used codons that were
preferentially used by the MS to
bacteriophage they used codons that
would avoid having GC rich regions
followed by a rich a T rich regions that
my terminate transcription and they use
codons that allowed them to generate all
of the nucleotides that would make the
gene synthesis easier and at about the
same time as gene sequences were being
revealed and published it was was
noticed right from right from the get-go
that the genes were using codons in a
non-random manner the sets of codons
were preferred over others and you can
see this this bias and codon usage and
codon usage tables and here here we have
one for human and one for e.coli and
what you can see for example you you
you 17.6 in human so that means it's the
uuu codon is used with a frequency of
17.6% core Don's right and then eco by
its 24.4 and so these kind of bias codon
usage tables are exist for pretty much
all organisms and if you if you look at
individual amino acids codons encoding
individual amino acids you can see that
it's it's not evenly distributed right
so for example for leucine in human c ug
is used with a frequency of 39.6 and CUA
with at 7.2 so that those are kind of
the extremes in in e.coli the extreme
goes from 37 point four to five point
six now interestingly in both cases c ug
is the most abundant codon for producing
and Cu a is the least abundant the the
others don't don't follow the same
ranking but so this gives you an idea of
bias and codon usage in different
organisms
there are a series of them I think of
fairly important observations that have
has led to quote on optimization
approaches and one is that it was
observed that highly expressed genes in
fast-growing organisms like e.coli
preferentially use a subset of codons
right so they're not used randomly and
some studies have shown that the bias
was correlated with tRNA abundance
another important observation is that
because the the code is genetic code is
degenerate almost all proteins can be
encoded by an almost infinite number of
mRNA sequences the third important
observation is that if you start looking
at the translation from those different
sequences they vary dramatically right
says so different synonymous mRNAs even
though they encode the same protein will
express that protein at very different
levels so if highly expressed genes use
a subset of codons our our codon bias
and protein expression causally linked
and if they are then it's probably would
be possible to enhance expression just
by mimicking the the bias that you see
in the highly expressed mRNA and his
prospect has led to the broad use of
quote on optimization and code on
modified constructs for bio production
gene therapy genetic vaccines and there
are many codon optimisation programs and
commercial services for doing this and
the different approaches vary and how
they measure codon bias different
variables that they consider their
applications how they implement them and
but the general feature of most is not
all of the approaches is to avoid using
rare codons which are thought to
decrease the rate of translation
elongation and limit protein synthesis
and so if different approaches quantify
codon usage in different ways and
different programs have different
features in some cases to make cloning
easier and for example you can add or
remove restriction sites so the
fragments I just emphasized can go to go
together easily or so that you can clone
into a specific vector and so the our
the nucleotide synthesis and design it
becomes an important feature and in some
cases for some of the programs that is
the primary goal of the programs and in
a lot of cases all you need to supply is
an amino acid sequence so the the
authentic codon uses of the gene is is
not a constraint at all and so you know
if you start just changing codons you
know willy-nilly you can run into other
problems and so a lot of the programs
considers some some of the some other
variables for example sequences that
might destabilize the message or that
might affect the context of the
initiation codon secondary structures in
the message that that might form with
with certain synonymous mRNAs but not
others repeated sequences the nucleotide
composition the presence the because of
the introduction of splice site that
might splice out a part of the mRNA
putative entry sites that might direct
translation to a different position in
the message promoter sequences that
might generate shorter RNAs for example
and in some of the programs also
consider information about the protein
structure itself right stop codon
dinucleotides that can affect cleave and
then so there are a lot of variables
that that are looked at because one once
you once you start changing
cotons you've disrupted the natural
sequences but to you in many cases
you've been reintroduced sequences that
will cause a problem and that has to be
taken into account and so because there
are so many different codons if you make
a message via one program or another /
they're good they're going to be
different because they approach they
approach the process in different ways
and for example some some approaches use
the most optimal or frequently used code
on every time a particular amino acid
comes up or a variation of that approach
top-2 for example other approaches
adjust codon usage so that it's more
proportional to the natural distribution
it approaches called code on
harmonization so you try to maintain
regions where you have rare codons so
you try not to disrupt protein folding
for example other approaches use
information about using codons that
might correspond to abundant tRNAs or
just selectively replacing the rare
codons but keeping other other things
more or less the same or avoiding codon
pairs like - inside which in some cases
are known to slow down translation and
with codon optimisation it's a it really
is not one solution that solves all
problems and in the first specific
applications of of this technology so in
some cases it's used to when you're
expressing an mRNA from one organism and
the different organism is to try to use
the codon bias of the host right which
is that which is about to give you a
protein that might more closely mimic
what was in the the original organism in
some cases is used to design RNA i
resistant genes for gene rescue
experiments different approaches have
been used for DNA
vaccines and gene therapy that's
interesting his plasma is with
unmethylated cpg motifs can activate
vertebrate immune systems and so the
plasmids that are made for these
applications are art unmethylated but
different c2g motifs can either
stimulate or neutralize the immune
response and so they've become an
important consideration for DNA vaccine
and gene therapy plasmids and so for
example for DNA vaccines it is useful to
stimulate the immune system and so could
quote on optimization programs designed
for that application will maximize the
number of immunostimulatory motifs and
decrease the immuno neutralizing
multi-and for gene therapy you don't
want to activate demons and so it you do
that the other way around and so it's a
badass that's basically a little bit
about codon optimization but the whole
process is based on a number of
assumptions which I'd like to get into
in a little bit more detail here and so
three others are probably more but we'll
take a look at three of the underlying
assumptions of codon optimization one
rare codons are rate limiting for
protein synthesis two synonymous codons
are interchangeable and free replacing
rare codons increases protein production
so one rare codons limit protein
synthesis there's actually very little
evidence that this is true there's
evidence in for examinee coli with
highly expressed genes but except for
those sorts of examples the correlations
between codon uses and expression are
very weak and in a lot of cases the
codon bias can be accounted to the large
extent just by the GC content of genomes
some studies have shown that translation
rates of different specific codons don't
correlate with tRNA
abundance or frequency of quran use and
if you think about it it seems would
seem almost unlikely that a rare codon
would be limiting for translation since
most of it most of the codons can be
decoded by more than one tRNA by wobble
base pairing and so just taking a look
at this in a little more detail and so
in this in this histogram work i plotted
the codon frequency the same thing that
was in that table so codon frequency for
a thousand codons versus different
codons and you can see it so if you look
at this is human data if you look at the
rarest ten codons they they all have a
cognate trna so they all have a gene
that can decode them but the rarer state
also has can also be decoded by Wabble
right and if we look at the difference
in in codon frequency it's about ten
fold from the highest to the lowest but
if you look at it a little bit more
closely what you find is that the amino
acids that are encoded the most often
tend to have more codons right and so if
you take that into consideration and you
normalize it number remember codons per
amino acids then these differences go
from about ten fold to about three fold
and so another issue that I've been
wondering about is whether rare codons
are even categorized correctly and and I
try to explain my concerns here so there
are a number if you think there are a
number of limitations of the codon usage
tables right so there Copeland's of
these codons and and I had it in my
circular representation they're rare or
abundant just based on the end the codon
table just based on their occurrence in
coding sequences and this is without
considering among mRNA levels right so
codon usage in an abundant message
is considered the same as in a rare
message right it's it's one-to-one codon
usage is considered only for the the
orful interest but we know that there is
a lot of alternative initiation that
occurs at both in-frame alternative even
frame initiation codons and out of frame
initiation codons and these are not even
considered it would be very difficult to
consider them at this one but these are
not even considered when codon usage is
is evaluated even though they would
probably dramatically skew codon usage
so quota usage in human it's just kind
of an overall score tissue-specific
differences aren't are taken into
consideration which messages and the
codon usage in those messages and you
know if you're rare or if you're if
you're limiting or if you're not I think
it has more to do with the levels of the
tRNA the cognitive and the Wobble tRNAs
then then the codon frequency and I
think you can just as easily imagine
that a rare codon is the one that would
be limiting if the tRNA is limiting
right so it's and again this is this is
rarely considered so there is very
little evidence that rare codons limit
protein synthesis and this is this is
supported by a different line of studies
which which indicate that translation
initiation is the step that is rate
limiting for protein synthesis not
elongation and this is a this is a
notion that I think the translation
field accepts generally as a fact so the
second assumption that synonymous codons
are are interchangeable so the soundest
quote has work I mean they were thought
of as silent
shins or silent changes because the
amino acid sequence wasn't changed and
it was believed that the amino acid
sequence was all it was necessary to
give you a same protein synonymously
patient's were thought to be neutral
during evolution and this is this was
elaborated in the neutral theory of
molecular evolution for a few years back
but more recently cited studies have
shown that synonymous mutations are
associated with human disease and
there's a growing list of diseases that
it's greater than 50 at this point that
are associated with synonymous mutations
and it's becoming clear that different
mRNAs even though they are including the
same protein don't give you the
equivalent protein and the effects can
be at multiple different levels
different changes can affect the
splicing stability how efficiently you
initiate translation elongation altered
kinetics and business is an important
point protein folding and and finally
when you when you change the codons
you're maintaining the amino acid coding
information but you're disrupting any
other information that's encoded in the
primary sequence and this includes any
sequence elements that might base pair
to other RNAs such as micro RNAs or
ribosomal RNAs and if you affect to
disrupt these sequences but you can you
could affect translation at many levels
including initiation represent with
shunting pausing frame shifting means
and so on and so that here's a here's a
paper that that makes this point
everything very well in bacteria so in
this study it was genome-wide analysis
of pausing translational pausing in
bacteria they use the ribosome profiling
technique which so they could they can
monitor where the ribosomes were we're
sitting on the message deep sequencing
of the ribose
protected fragments and what they found
was the rare you know codons decoded by
rare tRNAs did not slow translation so
there was no pausing under those
conditions in rich growth conditions but
where they did find pausing were in
coding regions that had sequences that
look like the shine-dalgarno sequence
and the Saratoga no sequence in bacteria
is used to initiate translation it base
pairs to the ribosomal RNA in the small
ribosomal subunit and gives you this
interaction and what they found were
sacs and are no like sequences in the
coding region and this I think in this
study they showed that that particular
interaction could account for about 70
percent of the major pause sites in the
messages and then this was done using
some some elegant techniques using
orthogonal ribosomes the third
assumption that replacing rare codons
increases protein production so there
there are a lot of studies that are
published that to show that codon
optimisation of message x wires that has
higher expression but these are all
individual examples and most cases
they've not been analyzed systematically
and they haven't looked at other
variables that could affect expression
and they don't they don't indicate if if
they tested multiple codon optimize
messages and this is the one that were
they all work or so anyway without that
additional evidence without doing it in
a more systematic way if you can't tell
if it's the results are due to quote on
alter the codon bias or two other
variables and there's a study here from
Plotkin's group coding sequence the
terminus of gene expression in e.coli
which it's kind of highlights some of
the variables and and I think it's a
very nice study so in this study what
they did is they generated library of
154 green fluorescent protein
Jeanne's right so all of the genes made
the same protein but they buried in the
codon use right and so they change
synonymous codons at 226 out of 240
positions and constructs differed by up
280 nucleotides so when they express
these constructs what they found is that
fluorescence level varied by 250 forth
across the library and what was what was
very interesting about this was that
codon bias didn't seem to correlate with
little fluorescence so the codon biasing
the expression didn't seem to be related
and nor did the number of rare codons
the number of pairs of consecutive rear
codon for the number of optimal quote on
what what accounted for most of their
data was the predicted structure in the
in the first 1/3 of the message through
the folding energy that correlating very
strongly with fluorescence I think it
accounted for more than 10 times as much
of the data as any of the other
variables so that when you had more
structure around the initiation code you
had less expression and less
fluorescence so is this this resulted in
bacteria even relevant to eukaryotic
cells I think it is because the similar
trends of reduced stability around
initiation codon reported in a number of
studies our own work as well as many
published studies and this appears to be
a kind of a universal phenomenon so the
accessibility appears to be a one of the
most if not the most important factor
that determines whether or not a
potential initiation codon is used to
initiate translation and another I think
important very important side is that
you don't see balloons as much codon
bias in high in higher eukaryotes as you
do in that in the highly expressed genes
bacteria and yeast right so the Lotus
glow is codon bias is reportedly in
mammals so so even even though the codon
use is so similar studies like the one
laughs I haven't performed yet in
mammalian cells there's I think this
little reason to expect that optimizing
the quarter you will excel in hands
expression since codon bias is a much
smaller phenomenon in in mammalian cells
and the accessibility is it appears to
be just as as strong a trait and so it
appears at least in in the microbes that
the highly expressed genes evolve an
optimal code unbiased but that the that
codon bias by itself isn't sufficient to
give you high expression that you do
require other features for example that
effect initiation or mRNA stability so
at the end of 2011 this paper came out
breaking the silence in Nature Medicine
and this is paper discussed quote on
optimization and some of some of the
potential problems which is it so
briefly review but it it indicated that
the whole approach of quote on
optimization is now on the FDA's radar
screen and it's it's a it's of some
concern so that there are because these
proteins are used as drugs there are
some important concerns in as I said
this is this is pretty much standard
practice right now code on optimization
and when you do this you're changing up
to about 80 percent of the nucleotides
in the coding sequence and you know what
can happen so you can you can end up
with a miss folded protein so you may be
increasing production of the protein but
that drug might be less efficient you
might not license you have that you
might present new epitopes on a on a
protein instead skin cause problems with
immunogen isset e you mean it initially
is a big problem with a lot of protein
drugs and and in fact
even the development of inhibitory
anti-drug antibodies which reduced the
effectiveness of the drugs it is a big
problem so the point of the point of
this talk was I wanted to discuss some
some new concerns and particularly for
applications that occur in vivo right so
like a gene therapy like an mRNA therapy
like a DNA or RNA vaccine and when one
of the problems has to do with the
production of novel peptides and so it's
generally assumed that when you're
making a construct you're going to
express the protein of interest and
you're going to initiate at the start
codon but this isn't true there's a huge
body of evidence which indicates that
this is not true and in fact when people
look translation usually starts from
multiple different sites within a
messenger RNA both in frame and out of
frame and both from Aug codons as well
as non canonical start sites right and
in in some cases these alternative open
reading frames actually make more
protein than the main sister own and in
what we found is that depending on the
manipulation you you can you can
modulate how much initiation is
occurring from one codon or another and
a lot of this has to do with
accessibility so an important example of
this comes from the major
histocompatibility complex and so in
vertebrates the the major
histocompatibility complex binds to
peptides and these come from endogenous
proteins are presented on the cell
surface that allows the immune system to
differentiate its self from from foreign
proteins now when people looked what
they find is that the peptides these
major histocompatibility peptides a lot
of them are encoded in alternative
reading frames and some of these
alternative reading frames initiate an
on a
cotons suggesting that you are
initiating not only at the authentic
start site but at other start sites in
other reading frames from various third
site and their strong evidence for this
alternative initiation from ribosome
profiling studies right so with the
ribosome profile and I've mentioned the
one study before you can map where the
ribosomes are single nucleotide
resolution and if you use a drug to
block translation initiation you can
identify the initiation complexes and
and when this is done in yeast and in
mammalian cells what you find is that
initiation complex is form at many
different sites within mRNAs and there
have been proteomic studies which have
provided data to show that these
initiation events are really occurring
so you're not you're not just getting
complex is formed on messages but you
actually are expressing those proteins
or peptides and so there have been
numerous mechanisms proposed how this
could occur right but at the present
time we still don't really know how
ribosomes go from the site of
recruitment on a message to the
initiation codon and so they the yoga
model that's generally accepted is
scanning and in that model that you get
to these other sites by processes called
leaky scanning or reinitiation our lab
we come up with some different models of
initiation that involve tethering or
clustering of the translation machinery
and these models can actually account
for many more of the observations in the
literature and describe a little bit how
I think how we think that this is
occurring so in the patterning ribosomal
complex is attached to the message at a
recruitment site in this case the m7g
cap structure and recognition of
initiation codon is a direct binding
reaction so the initiator trna base
pairs to an Aug codon which one will
depend on the distance from the
crewman site and the relative
accessibility and clustering is a
similar idea except the interactions
between the message and the translation
machinery are not as tight and so the
effect is is a kind of on-off
interactions that increase local in both
cases it's all about increased local
concentration and accessibility of of
aegs that you can base care to and so if
you imagine translation from a natural
message that has not been codon
optimized what would she what you'll get
is initiation and multiple different
sites now is that the the mechanism
doesn't matter the what's being produced
is the same that's empirical how we get
there doesn't really matter but it's a
it's drawn according to the tethering
mechanism and so you can imagine you if
you start at the AEG which is the first
start site in this message and the long
blue squiggle is is the polenta protein
there's also the possibility that you
can initiate at other start sites
including other au G's or non canonical
start sites like CU g or AC g or gu g
and when you're in frame you're going to
make a protein that resembles this the
full length but it's truncated and if
you're out of frame you're going to make
something completely different depending
on which reading frame you're in if you
have a quote on optimized message the
first thing is you will have disrupted
most if not all of those alternative
start sites and so you'll still make the
full-length protein you'll still make
truncated proteins that haven't for
example an Aug codon or a GG codon in
the same reading frame that hasn't
changed but all of the other frame
peptides will be different right so or
most of them will be different you will
have disrupted most of the natural out
of frame peptides and generate a new set
listen this is a worry because for in
vivo applications for a gene therapy and
RNA therapy Adi
actually an RNA vaccine these cryptic
products are being made inside the
patient right and unlike a protein drug
that's made in a bioreactor and purified
and these proteins these cryptic
products are purified away they're not
inside your body and these are novel
right and so the immune system is likely
to recognize them as foreign but they
may not be neutrals and they may they
may be hormones they may be toxin
you just don't know some of these may
have never been expressed before it ends
and so I think this is an enormous
concern another another potential
problem with code on optimizing
wholesale codon changes is that you're
altering mRNA editing within messages
and so RNA editing these are
post-transcriptional modifications that
would change specific nucleotides and so
I talked earlier about a 2 i editing in
the trna but this this also occurs in
mRNAs and it's these the predominant
editing type of editing in higher
eukaryotes and the substrate for it is
simply imperfect double stranded regions
of RNA so it it's likely that these can
be generated the problem with a 2 i
editing is that it changes you can you
changed you can change the amino acid
that's being encoded and so this can
have functional consequences and there
there are examples from real proteins
that are all that have a de y editing
that are functionally modified upon
editing right and this is a couple of
examples here nova one and he's doing
like growth factor binding protein 7
that show these sorts of effects
and so so if you if you if you've
altered the the post-transcriptional
modifications of the message say you've
gotten rid of what was normally there
you may have introduced new editing
sites and so you may have changed the
the coding potential of the of the
message or the splicing and like the
cryptic products you don't you don't
really know what the functional effects
might be or the toxicity of these of
these altered proteins these are either
novel these will be novel proteins and
the effects
well authenticity in the immune response
I think would be an obvious one but
there may be others as well and then so
summarize so there's a quote on usage of
many many genes has it has evolved under
different selective pressures or not
just it's not just the coding sequence
not just the amino acid sequence but
there are other factors other variables
that are selected for and codon
optimisation preserves the amino acid
sequence the coding potential but it in
doing so you lose a lot of the other
information for you at the primary level
for example that is encoded and in fact
the whole premise for codon optimisation
appears to be squad and for in vivo
applications for the applications where
constructs are going into people and the
proteins are being expressed in the
patient then there are other real
concerns I think so this all of the
concerns of altered protein conformation
still apply but in addition you're
making novel peptides that
thrown the dice you just don't know and
the same with the post-transcriptional
modifications and and so at this point I
think the use of quote on optimization
increased expression for these in vivo
applications may be pretty dangerous and
and should be thought about very very
carefully and I would just like to
acknowledge some of my funding sources
and take a look to see if there's any
questions
so what one question here is there any
information on the effect of the mRNA
sequence a different quote on
utilization same protein on the mRNA
exit from the nucleus to the cytoplasm
one could imagine that the mRNA sequence
with strong 3d structure around the fire
crime might have difficulty leading the
nucleus and therefore give less
translated protein I'm not sure if
there's any any studies that have that
have that app show had shown this or
have tested this it might might be it
might be a reasonable possibility but
yeah I just don't know if that's
anybody's actually looked at that in any
kind of a systematic way
here's a here's another question so in
order to preserve protein folding when
expressing it in a hetero law
heterologous system it seems a good
strategy to preserve the relative
ranking at each position now if you're
referring to the relative ranking of the
codons I I'm not sure I believe that the
codon usage tables really give you any
kind of a real indication of what's
abundant or real for a number of reasons
I'm not even sure that's something that
can be empirically determined to be
honest and when people have looked at
you know stretches of rare codons in
most cases they don't get the effect of
slowing which they expect I've seen some
examples of one example I can remember
where they did and and there are other
studies where in fact stretches of rare
codons can actually enhance elongation
and where people have suggested that it
might be something called tRNA
channeling where the reuse of the same
codon even if it's a rare codon enhances
translation so it's a I think it's more
more complex than just trying to
maintain a ranking especially when when
the basis for the ranking is suspect
okay
the so here's here's another question
sickle cell anemia an inherited genetic
disorder has origin and selective
pressure of malaria you think gene
therapy is better
we're just marriage counseling to avoid
birth of homozygous sickle cell patients
in the context of codon usage and lots
of risk in gene therapy well I think I
think this is out of my element to
listen to comment on it on this and my
basic scientists and as I can tell you
what what the risks are I'm not sure if
I could console for gene therapy
although I think I think the risks in
gene therapy could be minimized to a
huge extent if you if you if you if you
avoid the use of codon optimization but
the and in fact what are one of the
reasons I think this this should be
discussed is that I think things like
gene therapy and the vaccines I think
they have tremendous potential but if
it's done in the wrong way I think it
may lead to a lot of problems and in
some cases death which which would be
kind of a it would be a terrible and a
consequence of what I think is a
potentially very very promising
approaches and and and so I don't think
there are the risks are inherent
inherent as big as you might expect with
some of these approaches but the
manipulations that are done may make it
worse
so the question are the amino acid
transfers is also expressed
differentially and I'm not sure I mean I
would I would imagine so I would imagine
so
but while we
what we wait to see if any other
questions are coming in you put up this
last slide so if you you're looking for
educational credits because what you can
follow the link and and get some of your
continuing education credits and I don't
see any more questions so I would I
would say that when we're done here